so our next speaker
actually what he just started working
for
me 25 days ago and we told him on
Tuesday he had to give a talk so we're
hazing the new guy right but he has a he
has a very experienced career he was the
barista champion two years in a row so
if you ever need a corta he's the guy
who's going to do it for you everyone
please welcome Gus
hey everyone let's go back a slide so uh
like Jared said I actually volunteered
they only mildly hazed me um but I I'm
very excited to be here and talk about
machine learning for people and so
normally I hate agenda slides but since
I'm going to be all over the place today
I thought I'd give you guys one a little
softball so we've got some motivations
I'm going to set the stage for a story
and then we're going to talk through
that story and preview some data make
some models compare results and efficacy
and then think Beyond those those models
in this particular story and think how
we could apply these lessons to Future
ones and then sum everything up for a
nice little uh moral story and so
starting jumping in with our motivations
I want to know how can I create a model
that is easy to use and understand and
so in a world where we've got like chat
GPT and all that you don't actually
really know what's going on or how it
works and so if let's say you're
building a model for a less technical
team they really want to know what's
actually happening in your model if you
just give them a number and you go hey
my model says go do this they're like no
thanks that computer is not my boss and
if maybe you just care about the
measured impact of the independent
variables and not actually as much about
the end result of the model you're just
trying to figure out what's actually
going on here and why is this happening
and then a lot of the times these are
business questions rather than
technology questions and so if I set the
stage this is my old car it's a 2008 R 4
a base model four cylinder and I always
want to know when I'm driving how many
miles do I have remaining how far can I
actually go and so here's my instrument
cluster and we've got my fuel gauge my
gas
light and my trip odometer and so this
particular trip you'll notice I'm 327
miles in I'm on empty my gas light is on
and my tires are low on pressure I was I
was very worried about running out of
gas and a little bit of extra info for
you is this particular car gets 20 City
25 Highway and about 22 combined rated
from the
EPA and so I made myself a Google form
to collect my own data and every time I
went and got gas I always filled up I
always filled out my Google form or took
a picture of my instrument cluster and
then filled out the form
later and so over about two and a half
years with the car I always knew I had
my distance traveled I knew how many
gallons I had put in the car I had my
price per gallon I wanted to know if my
light was on and then I measured the
gauge level in the highest Fidelity I
could because it's continuous and I
rounded it to the nearest about quarter
so I said this is there are four tick
marks it's out of four and it actually
went from negative .25 because if I
really wanted to run it I could go below
empty and
so I ended up with 173 rows of
data and this is just a quick uh little
bit that it looked like so again gallons
price per gallon light gauge level and
distance and then a time stamp I never
really did anything with the time stamp
besides look at how much I was spending
on gas every month and I computed some
more columns I had my total cost gallons
remaining so I know or Toyota told me
that my G my tank was 15.9 gallons and
so I subtracted how many gallons I put
in and that's how much gas I had
remaining I have my miles per gallon how
much I spent per mile the actual amount
of gas like like the actual what the
gauge should have said percent error
between what the gauge said and what it
should have said and an estimated miles
remaining and so if I start thinking
about machine learning and how I can
apply it I've got some goals to keep in
mind I don't want to run out of gas and
because I'm driving I want to be able to
compute my miles remaining while I'm
sitting in the car and that's sort of
tricky because I can't pull out my phone
that's illegal and I would never break
the law
um and not just do I want to know how
many miles remaining like at one moment
if I pulled over let's say I want to
know at any time because maybe I'm
coming up to a rest stop and there's a
gas station it says next rest stop 70
miles am I going to make it who knows
and then I want to be able to share my
findings in easy to understand way
because it's hard to get people excited
about my gas mileage and so I I made a
few models I got some that are like to
work they produce continuous numeric
output so I can get any number
presumably out of there and then I can
calculate an error metric so the model
says I have 50 miles remaining I ran out
of gas after 40 my error was 10 miles
I've got some that need modification and
those produce a discrete numeric output
so I might not get every number I might
just get oh you have 50 miles or 70
miles or miles it could be one of those
or reduces probabilistic output which
would be you're going to run out of gas
or you're not going to run out of gas
and eror is a lot harder to calculate
without driving around and running out
of gas and so again if I use estimated
miles remaining I'll choose a metric in
this case for root mean squared error
which will just say this is how much of
a buffer you have before your model
might be wrong and you'll run out of gas
before you thought you would and then
again for the probabilistic one I can
use percent accuracy and so for the ones
that are likely to work I started with a
neural net because if we're going to
start big we might as well start with
the biggest and so I used the three like
I showed with my instrument cluster I've
got those three variables available to
me my gauge level my light and my my
trip odometer and for this particular
neural net I gave it a th000 Epoch and
10 10 hidden units it was definitely
Overkill with less than 200 rows but
that's okay
and some pros for this particular model
it's quite accurate it's very cool to
use and very hip and if I say hey guys I
made a neural net to tell me how far I
can go in my car everyone's like wow
you're so cool I go thanks guys and then
con's it's not easy to do on the Fly I
don't really know what's going on and I
can't share it with you and it's
computationally
expensive and So my poor phone it's
plugged in it's trying to run Android
auto and this neural net it might not
have happen alternatively I could step
back a bit and I could use a simple
decision tree where this one again I fed
it all three variables it turns out this
particular implementation only decide to
use my gas gauge which is handy because
it means it's less for me to think about
and I just have one tree and it's easy
to understand it's easy to execute I can
say hey my gas gauge is at one and so I
go yes it's less than 1.4 no it's
greater than 63 yes it's less than 1.1 I
might have 113 miles remaining who knew
but it could be
better distance and gauge level does
imply miles per gallon so by losing
distance we're losing some
implied uh metrics there because if my
gauge is at let's say three out of four
and my distance is 100 miles I'm
probably getting pretty good gas mileage
and so we're losing that miles per
gallon and then there's some
memorization involved where now I either
have to print it out and look at this
and that's not much better than texting
or I just have to memorize
it with random Forest if you're not
aware it's basically taking about a
thousand of these but they're all
slightly different and then averaging
them out and so this one I don't really
know how many of those trees used which
of my three main variables but I made a
thousand of them it's very accurate it's
not massive computationally expensive
compared to let's say the neural net
because decision trees are relatively
simple and you're just doing a lot of
them cons it's not easy to do on the fly
if I'm going to struggle with one
decision tree I'm definitely going to
struggle doing a thousand of them
because that's probably going to take me
a solid hour and a half and at that
point I'm dead on the road again and
it's pretty difficult to communicate
because again I can tell you one
decision tree maybe I could give you
two you don't want me to give you a th
decision
trees and then if we step over to a
simple regression a linear regression
and I'm just using gauge level um it's
easy to understand it's easy to execute
because I have this equation down here
and I say okay my gauge is at one I'm
going to make this easy for myself then
I've got
66.2 plus
55.94 and then I'm too stressed
presenting to do that math in my head
but it could be a little bit better
again distance and gauge level implies
miles per gallon and it does require
that Mental Math which again you might
be too checked out on the highway to do
or maybe mental math isn't really your
strong suit but that's
okay we can make it more complicated for
you we can give you multiple linear
regression and so instead of just using
gauge level We'll add in light and
distance and it's still relatively easy
to communicate because if I show you
this and then I say okay just pretend
there's more variables and this line is
in four dimensions instead of two you go
oh yes of course the fourth dimension so
simple and it's quite accurate but again
there's a lot more mental math and
because you're trying to think in four
or five Dimensions it's not as easy to
understand and if your your car if
you're bringing this home you probably
have more variables you can use at your
disposal so since I sold this car I now
have my car's own estimated miles
remaining and I could add that in and
now I've got more and more variables
building it
out and so now I've got the ones that
need some modification they don't quite
tell me miles remaining they're more of
a here I'm making you do some work too
and so if I do a clustering algorithm
where again I'm using all three of my
variables and I'm building out 10
centers and so that just means I have
all of my data sort of plotted out in
that multi-dimensional space I try and
find the 10 closest groups I can end up
with this table of centroids I say it's
easy to execute and that's on the math
side watching how K means works is
actually really neat and I do recommend
it but it's easy to execute because as
long as I have this table with me I can
go yeah I've gone like 280 miles my
lights on and my gauge is at zero so I
probably have about 65 miles remaining
but there's lots of human factors in
interpretation it can be difficult to
choose a row if you're in
between it's kind of difficult to
communicate because I saw you all
nodding uh yes K
means and there's no real good measure
of accuracy because at this point I
already I only know do I have about 47
miles or am I going to run out of
gas over to logistic regression things
get worse if I only use my gauge level I
have to convert and say do I have less
than 50 miles remaining I can't get that
nice how many miles it's now do I have
50 miles left or not it's easy to
understand it is relatively accurate
but it's basically the same as the gauge
level because if you actually plug gauge
level into this
equation when your gauge is at .25 which
is the lowest it goes then this produces
yes you have less than 50 miles but I
already knew that because my gauge is
below
empty so if we then yeah it's I I did do
the math a few times I was like what if
I put it in at zero and it comes back is
no you have more than 50 miles I was
like this is great and you can see it
again from the distribution of the dots
um and so if we do compare the models um
we'll use estimated eror or error and
estimated miles remaining we got our
root mean square error as our y AIS our
simple decision tree well relatively
easy to use has some of the worst error
we build we get a little bit better with
simple linear then multiple linear which
is actually very close to neural net and
then random Forest blows the other
models out out of the water and K means
and logistic regressions do have bars
they it's not that they're failing to
load they just you can't measure error
it's maybe they get it right maybe they
don't but you're never going to have a
good sense until it actually happens and
so in classic apple fashion just like
the color scheme on my slides I'm giving
you a chart with no y AIS and I'm saying
higher is better and so I did I did uh
pass my tables around there are numbers
Behind These I pass them around to the
my team at Lando and I said all right
how do you feel about ease of use for
these different models and we we agreed
simple linear models are pretty easy
it's it gives you a a y- axis it gives
you an x- axis you do a little bit of
math and then you just you plot your
points pretty simple a decision tree
again the problem there is it's a lot
more from the simple linear K means you
just have that table again you have to
memorize it multiple now you're doing a
lot more math logistic regession
again depending on where your equation
is at you might actually have to do one
equation to get your odds and then
another equation to convert to
probability and at that point again
you've missed your gas station and then
good luck using a neuronet or a random
Forest while you're on the
go and if we look at communication so
I'm trying to tell all of you about
these models and for me at least telling
you about simple decision trees and
linear models are it's pretty easy same
with logistic it doesn't perform as well
but it's easy to communicate and once
you have the ideas behind simple linear
adding in multiple linear isn't too bad
same with random forest and simple
decision trees K means not so bad and
then neural Nets it's easy just handwave
and go it works like your brain it
doesn't but you can handwave it for most
people and so what did I actually use to
estimate my miles remaining and this is
really like the the big question here
and the answer is I used my brain I to
be honest I never made any of these
models until earlier this week and I
sold the car a month and a half ago
so so I did try and really chart out I
was like okay what am I actually doing
when I'm sitting in my car and it's
basically a decision tree kind of and so
I look I would look at my gas gauge or
my light or my distance and I did I get
I would get really antsy when I hit 270
miles cuz I knew I had enough of a
buffer to make it to Costco for cheap
gas but if I got there I might have to
turn the car off in the parking lot
because I wasn't sure if I'd make it to
the pump if my light was on I should
probably get it just because it seems
like the responsible thing to do is a as
an adult or if my gauge is a little bit
too low then I might want to start
thinking about it and as I'm sitting
here charting this out and going okay
what's what nodes do I need to add what
decision points do I need to add I
realized it's basically decision tree
meets C's table um I've rotated that
chart 90° but really all I did was in my
head I went okay I've gone like 290
miles my light is on and my gauge is at
zero so I should probably get gas soon
it's not so much that I'm following any
one thing strictly but as a person I've
built my own mental model of when I
should get gas and so if we think beyond
the gas tank cu I said the word gas a
little bit too much and surprised I
haven't gotten it confused with my own
name then we can think about maybe
Hospital patient readmissions so instead
of thinking how often are people
readmitted to our hospital we can think
what is influencing those readmission so
once we build the model and say okay
let's say I have a very low chance of
being readmitted because I'm a young
healthy adult male but if I was an old
frail man and I went in a snowboard
accident I'd probably have a high chance
of being readmitted but but that's not
important to know what is important to
know is that I'm
old I'm not doing great healthwise and
those are the likely things to bring me
back and what's convenient for a
hospital in that situation is they can't
do anything about you being old but they
can do some other things that I've got
talks on my uh website you can look at
about it or if you want to go to Disney
World you can try and predict your wide
weight times but that's not really
helpful because you don't care how long
the weight is you already know they tell
you how long the weight is what you want
to know is what's influencing those
weight times so if weight times get
shorter during fireworks that's a really
good thing to know and they do or if
there's a parade people want to go see
the parade go sneak in on your favorite
ride and it again it's not about the
output of the model and telling you what
the actual time will be but finding all
of the factors that influence it and for
standardized test course a little bit of
a hot button topic these days but some
people may do better just because of
where they grew up the schools they went
to the environment they had and so
saying oh we're going to predict SAT
scores it turns out the best predictor
for SAT scores is actually zip code and
so it's not how much time they spent
studying it's not the schools they went
to but kind of is because a lot of the
times people go to Neighborhood
schools and so if we try and think about
it as a whole accuracy is great uh like
Jared's yesterday wherever he went
more complex models can produce
fantastic results but they can also be a
lot more wasteful for marginal gains and
sometimes they're actually a little bit
worse and so accuracy is good but so is
explainability and executability and
sometimes it's okay to sacrifice a
little bit of that accuracy so that you
can communicate it to the people around
you so that all of you have a better
idea of what's going on and that my
friends is machine learning for
people